hey everyone hi drew i'm julianne huff
and i'm nina dobrev
and we're best friends and we also
happen to have a
wine company that we are so excited for
you all to enjoy and share
but first and foremost we are going to
play a game today yes we are
most likely drew superlatives
most likely to take the longest to get
ready to go out
what's this i think it's an equal thing
because it's not fair because we get
hair and makeup done
and we do it together at the same time
you're sitting there and taking your
vitamins
today or ten years ago because those are
different answers
if it's a ten years ago i think
definitely me
if it's a today thing it's equal no
it's i am matured yeah by the way
why more mature taking long to get ready
is not a bad
thing it just means that you're just you
get highly distracted
in certain things and so you like like i
said
you have such a thing with supplements
and you have your supplements everywhere
and you're doing this and you're doing
that and you're taking the dogs out and
it's just like
it's all the things okay yeah there's
nothing wrong with that
okay the best gift giver is
really yeah you are so excellent at
giving gifts
oh yeah i feel like you are huh that
means we really
love each other's gifts
[Laughter]
most likely to give the best dating
advice
i would say in the past it used to be me
but right now it's her i think that's
what's cool about friendship is you go
in waves and
you know one person is kind of like in a
a rhythm
of life in different areas and then the
other person is kind of
you know doing this and you switch back
and forth so yeah i used to be that
person
now it's nina most likely to start
cleaning their house
while they're having a house party
me honestly is there any way to point
more
you clean as you go so you're not
overwhelmed by the end of the night
but also like aesthetically it's just
more pleasing to the eye
when you're enjoying yourself and you
see a clean kitchen
or you know when there's crap everywhere
it's not as
pleasing to the experience see i have a
different philosophy
the way i see it is that's
tomorrow nina's problem and
she'll figure it out tomorrow but have
you ever
seen me not enjoy myself while i'm
having a party
for sure i'm not saying you find joy in
doing that
you like things to be like i love so
yeah
i'm not i'm not judging i think you're
like you are happy to do it
well i'm off in the corner just like
doing your thing
yeah totally it's true i don't even
realize i'm cleaning when i'm doing it
it's just happening
i'm dancing i always invite her to all
of my parties
people love when i why do you think
we're such good friends
so speaking about parties what's a party
without drinks
well i think we're gonna sign some
superlatives for the wine
hell yeah here we go most likely to be
the first one to open a bottle of wine
after a long day
most likely to pair fine with something
random
i feel like everything that you p you
you're always like it's very thought out
yeah
you're right yeah and i'll just kind of
open it for any occasion
with food without food in the fields
in the house in a i do all that too
yeah i think you just open it with like
you'll eat like
something random with it most likely to
open a bottle of wine without a bottle
opener handy
i would say 100
i've actually done it how with a machete
like one of those did you say a machete
yeah where did you get a machete like do
you just carry a machete in your purse
it was like a party trick that someone
taught me that where you like can open
you can like saw off the top of a bottle
it's not safe
please do i don't try this sure that's
champagne yeah
yeah that's dude i haven't done it yet
but i could i think okay
i would try to like use some sort i
would use a hanger who has wire hangers
anymore by the way
people do the wire ones most likely to
spill a glass of wine
while together this one right here
most accident prone person on the planet
i've already spilled it a couple times
over the zoom
yeah um anybody have a carpet cleaner
actually i think drew said that she uh
she had it out of a blue shag rug
carpet yeah yeah we'll have to we'll
have to get some of that stuff drew
help us out here that was most likely
drew superlatives cheers guys that was
fun we could
make that into a drinking game that we
do all the time all the time
i love that game thank you drew thank
you for having us we're
happy to be here bye guys
you